nein
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem
weiteren video auf meinem kanal und zwar
befinde ich mich hier auf den hd servern
bei den servern und ich habe sehr viele
kommentare letzter zeit bekommen hey
conny deine neuen videos und die dich
halt mal so ein bisschen mehr bearbeitet
und so sind zwar ganz cool aber wir
möchten einfach so ein richtiges
oldschool pvp video von dir sehen und da
frage ich mich natürlich erst mal warum
wollt ihr pvp von mir sehen ich bin der
übeltäter knop in pvp und ich werde ich
sehe schon wieder kommen viele leute
schreiben jetzt wieder die kommentare
du kannst gar nichts lernt malblock ins
café und alles mögliche nein ich bin es
nicht lernen ich bin ganz zufrieden
damit dass ich nicht so gut bin im pvp
ich möchte damit auch nicht groß
beschäftigen aber ich hab gedacht auch
pvp hat ja auch nicht so viel mit so
schlagen und so zu tun sondern mehr mit
montag kicken
ich muss echt sagen also ich gehe jetzt
erstmal ganz kurz hier irgendwo eine
lobby rein hier beispielsweise zwölf von
zwölf können mich dann kam auf start
klicken gestaltet das sehr schön
und zwar muss ich echt sagen ich hab
auch sehr sehr stark ein tech spektrum
an dass du mir leid niemand shader ich
habe auch sehr sehr wenig verfolgt also
ich habe ab und zu mal bei irgendwem
reingeschaut und so was alles aber jetzt
nicht irgendwie das ich weiß okay hier
wohnt der und der und hier darf ich mich
am besten nicht aufhalten und hier
völlig relativ leicht runter sondern es
ist halt wirklich so dass ich da nicht
so viel von
mit geschaut habe weil ich nicht der
große skype blog fänden es geht in fünf
minuten 40 - und ich sollte mich
eventuell ein bisschen verschanzen
ich weiß allerdings das spielprinzip
also die pvp vollen hab ich echt mal
gerne geschaut wurde mit dem action am
start war
ich weiß das spielprinzip ist man muss
jemand runter geht und ich habe mehrere
verschiedene items wie beispielsweise
ändert mit denen ich mich irgendwohin
teleportieren kann wenn ich runter falle
schneebälle mit denen die werte leute
runter klicken kann aber keinen schaden
zufügen kann
ein bisschen mehr zu fressen einen gold
apfel einen creeper ein trank der
heilung die wissen hat sich in der rolle
bin scheiße beim eintrag der
schnelligkeit und eine angel mehr habe
ich nicht und jetzt hier noch so falsch
uhr das sicher nicht irgendwo unter
falle nicht so viel falsch aden bekomme
ich möchte jetzt einfach mal dieses
video beispielsweise nicht so viel
bearbeiten nicht akzeptiert ich möchte
eigentlich gar nicht so viel bearbeiten
in diesem video sondern wirklich einfach
so old school kommt rüdiger der ist nur
auf mich fokussiert der pizza denn du
sollst auf die anderen gehen die glauben
ich bin master der verbilligten
ich bin wie ich bin
dieser krieg sei was will der denn der
geht nur auf mich einfach
ich weiß also ich hab ich das gewinnen
sollte freunde natürlich allen als aus
bei den nächsten video days
das ist explodiert report neben mir aber
gar kein schaden gemacht irgendwie so
wir sind jetzt hier bei einer
ich bin jedoch ich kann jedoch in den zu
unterfallen oder wieso schlägt er mich
dann mal einen fall schaden zu sterben
ist ja echt schwierig würde ich sagen da
hinten ist einmal jetzt jetzt jetzt
kommt fall runter darunter falle auch
weil doch die so ruckelt das denn jetzt
so scheiß 60 fps scheiße tom willst da
gucke ich lieber keine bälle
hier geht jetzt mal ich gebe mich
geweckt und er steht einfach nur um
alter und guckt grad wahrscheinlich
irgendwo geht doch mal auf ihn hier er
ist doch gerade hier irgendwie abbauen
also den müssen wir jetzt erstmal
irgendwie hierunter kicken wo jetzt ist
er auch noch was einen besseren score
comline einheiten wo ist er hin
diese ganzen diese sache mit den anderen
sex ein bisschen verwirrend jetzt geht
es aber dass auch er heftig ab juni sind
richtig viele leute
er muss einfach mal einer jetzt eine
piper trank irgendwie part rangenommen
prix pathé irgendwie sondern so einen
creepers borner hinwerfen ich verziehe
mich jetzt erstmal hier so ein bisschen
ich komme in höhe von oben wenn ich das
irgendwie hinkriege
was geht neuer pc ist unterwegs
eine der bomben das habe ich knapp
schade der welt fast unter geflogen weil
da kann ich herunterfallenden hier ist
ist eine absperrung ich erst mal ganz
kurz was massen fall tja man es wirklich
so alter hier sind so viele leute am
start
ich trinke jetzt mal trank der
schnelligkeit wie youtube das keiner
hinter mir okay wir sind auch sind auch
alle am leben glaube ich sind noch zehn
leute am start mit zwölf leuten server
dann bin ich auf jeden fall schon mal
nicht letzter reiter jetzt richtiger
massen weiter vorne ist ein chronisches
noch wo man so und ich weiß noch wo man
so andere unterstützen kann ich hab kein
bock dass ich möchte ich möchte unter
die top 5 kommen dass mein ziel
ich muss doch jetzt mal
verpisst euch habt ihr alle regale weg
erklärt dass eine runter gefallen und da
ist nummer dagegen erst nach seinem
vater weg oder riskiert 1 gehen und so
wegfliegen sterben oder macht irgendwas
was niemanden sonst hier ich muss es
nicht muss es nicht wissen wie lang habe
ich noch schnelligkeit acht sekunden
noch okay etwas blöd dass die ganze
sache nicht schon verschwendet habe aber
ich denke ich bin gleich tot
7 einfach noch zehn leute keiner stirbt
irgendwie aber das chaos gerade alter da
stehe ich da an der zaunbauer ja dass
jemand runter geschlittert habt ihr euch
mein jenseits wer bin ich eigentlich
nicht wenn mich nicht master data ich
hab kein runter geschleudert ich bin
jonathan 13 21 uhr unbesetzt ist
mastercard uhr
aber da ist raum oder ich weiß nicht was
er wolle nicht unter gesprungen ok jetzt
jetzt ab die beiden sind da unten drin
peter wie so wartet er denn da so auf
mich ich weiß dass ich das bin denn der
schilder an der leiter und youtube ding
gar nicht dass auch noch andere am start
sind
zwar konnten die beiden captains einfach
mal ich beobachte das ganze mal von oben
ich warte einfach bis einer irgendwie
unter fliegt dann komme ich da zwischen
medizin anderer kommt mich in die lava
kleines bisschen scheiße
komm ich jetzt einfach mal selber hier
unterrichtet mal den brain scotty
wiederholen der brain scotty wider
erwarten dafür hin so eklig allerdings
fehlt doch jetzt aus nicht in die lava
nicht in die lava luca das ist ganz
wichtig nicht in die lava nicht in die
lava okay er brennt verbrannte verzieht
sich mit der ender perle da gehe ich
jetzt mal direkt hinterher
in einer andern ein umgeht er denn jetzt
auf mich pizza der bretagne ist ja die
lava gefallen ist denn die lava gefallen
wo sehen derzeit muss er hindert mich
aber wohl noch geboxt irgendwie ach die
sind jetzt hier oben gekommen
er ist nur noch fünf spieler am start
eventuell wird das was freunde ein
bisschen drauf los jetzt hier auf 22
jetzt klingt das ist man der der ist
schon die ganze zeit nur im berglauf
jetzt ist auch dann verletzt ist okay
was geht mein zweites unter
okay was ist mit dem dahinter wir sind
wenn er nicht seinen stock zum passen
ok jetzt ist china da unten alter der
der lotse nicht immer daran
komm jetzt ruckelt das hier wieder so
kommt am kamp in solchen moment ist es
echt so kanns echt sein dass jemand da
an wo nicht in die lava nicht in die
lava nicht in die lager nicht in die
lava nicht in die lava jetzt erst mal
das essen ich muss das essen nein ich
bin mir aber ich bin in der lava
kommentar appellen und nein nein nein
wo bin ich denn fakt kommt komm komm
komm ich bin wo ich will dich fahrrad
irgendwo neu wie sie schreiben ja eine
scharte wieder wusste dass ich 100 bin
wenn man das verstehe ich immer nie na
ja das war's mit aura pvp ich wollte das
ganze auf jeden fall mal antesten
deshalb jetzt nicht sogar geklappt weil
zwischendurch mal so ein paar lex hatte
und so was alles mögliche aber ich bin
eigentlich zufrieden mit der runde
ihr könnt das ganze spielen auf den
sommer hd.de servern so die sogar ins
web seite das schon krass was die wir
zusammen gemacht haben
tvp die cvp ist nicht so mein fall und
skywalk find ich jetzt noch nicht so
krass ein bisschen schon ausgelutscht
damals fand es cool aber was die aus
diesem pvp projekt gemacht da muss ich
sagen hut ab ist auf jeden fall eine
coole sache und ich hoffe euch hat das
video gefallen ich weiß ich bin schweiz
im pvp muss mir die kommentare schreiben
dafür werde ich nur bestätigt und hollow
komischer typ wenn es euch gefallen hat
so mit einer bewertung und dann würd ich
sagen sehen wir uns in einem anderen
video wieder wo ich dann auch wieder
heftig basieren